it's not a bird and it's not a plane
it's a new actor playing Superman and
the internet already has strong feelings
about the casting for James Gunn's
upcoming Superman film
ever since Superman Legacy was announced
there has been Fierce speculation on who
would be cast in the roles and how
filmmaker James Gunn will handle this
fresh new take on the iconic character
though we don't have much to go on so
far for the project we do know that the
film is set to be released on July 11
2025 making it still roughly two years
off still that hasn't stopped the
passionate discourse between fans over
who's going to be wearing that red cape
and tights in Superman Legacy and
naturally that discussion also includes
wondering who will be showing up as Lois
Lane Clark Kent's fellow reporter and
love interest now however the
speculation can finally come to an end
as the two main stars of the film have
just been announced David korinswett is
set to take on the main double role as
Superman Clark Kent and Rachel Brosnahan
is stepping into the shoes of Plucky
sarcastic reporter Lois Lane Gunn
confirmed the casting on Twitter saying
of the two stars accurate they are not
only both incredible actors but also
wonderful people congressman and
self-described comic book nerd Robert
Garcia responded incredible castings
James Gunn this is the way there's no
better way to kick off the new DCU than
with Superman David Koren sweat has been
seen most recently as the unnamed
projectionist and love interest to me at
goth's titular character and Ty West's
Pearl a role where he definitely has
Superman's trademark charm cornswat was
also in all six episodes of the HBO
miniseries we own the city where he
played David McDougall the actor clearly
looks the part so it's no surprise
really that fans have been so positive
about his casting in Superman Legacy one
Twitter user wrote Amazing James both of
my desired picks land the role can't
wait to see what you and the crew put
together another fan even took the time
to ride out specifically why he thinks
corn sweat is the perfect man for the
job in Superman Legacy though corn sweat
is a lesser-known entity as a performer
even those who don't know his work well
seem to support his casting one fan
wrote welcome aboard King another fan
tweeted this is absolutely great casting
Superman Legacy is off to a great start
as for Rachel Brosnahan who's set to
play Lois Lane fans may be more familiar
with her work especially if they've
watched a certain critical darling
television series rosnahan starred in
The Marvelous Mrs maisel as the titular
character Maria maisel I'm really glad
to be back in New York City my home
where I have so many friends who hate me
the well-received series recently
concluded on Prime video marking 2023 as
a pretty big year for the star overall
one fan tweeted I don't know who that
guy is but Kudos on Rachel she was made
for that role another wrote Rachel is a
phenomenal actress from marvelous Mrs
maisel both great actors can't wait for
Superman Legacy DCU lfg one fan even
went so far as to compare her to
arguably our most iconic Lois Lane yet
Rachel Brosnahan is giving Marco Kidder
Vibes and I'm here for it well if the
collective response across social media
to the casting of our new Superman and
Lois Lane and Superman Legacy is any
indication it looks like fans are
overall pretty happy with the news